YOUTUBE REWIND!
!DNIWER EBUTUOY
The new YouTube Rewind is up!
*slow claps*
And I thought I would react to it for a good ol'-
good ol' time
I've been a part of YouTube Rewind since
uhhh
It's always been very cool to be a part of, I remember when they did the first one.
Everyone that wasn't in it was like, "Holy, holy heck! ...
(Christian channel)
... I would love to part of that, that looks cool!"
And I remember in the comments in the 2012 one, I wasn't in it
and people were so pissed cause I think I just became the biggest channel or something like that
and they was like, "Where. Is. PewDiePie?????"
But I was invited for 2013, it was a very fun and easy shoot.
They came to Brighton to shoot it with me.
I can't believe I've been in Brighton for so long..
I was like a little easter egg in the end.
Because of all the comments in the last video they were like, "Alright, we'll put him in the end so people—" The tension! Will he be in this one?!
Who knows????
There it is!
Man... I look soo different.
They just asked me to do a bunch of weird stuff with it. I'm like "I don't know.. I'll scream at it.."
But it was cool, it was a really fun shoot.
I think rewind for me, has always been really good because— and (for) YouTubers in general, cause it's such a huge production
We're not really used to being in front of cameras with other people.
For me, it was really good practice. because whenever you're here it's my space, I know .. my stuff but like
if you have a whole crew in front of you with their cameras, I don't know who they are? I don't even think they know who I am?
And then you're expected to do your thing, like that's super weird so...
I though rewind was really good to like get more practice.
I loved this one. I actually got a bigger part in this one which I thought was
pretty deserved, you know?
Uhhh... and it was also in Brighton.
This one took forever to film.
My god— we went soo overtime. Literally everyone left.
Still. I loved filming this one.
First of all, it turned out fucking great.
I actually had to jump through like an actual piece of wood or something like that
You have to be brave. I did it so many times, I must've done it at least 10 times.
Uhh, and it started really hurting after awhile.
I had a stunt- professional stuntman helping me out and it was so fun.
It was suuuper fun. I loved it.
2015 everybody!
This one was weird. I'm not gonna lie. I was like...
They were like, "Okay so you're gonna be with Zoella" I'm like...
Okay..
Why not Marzia?
You know she's lives in Brighton too, right, like...???
Like why isn't Zoella with Alfie, he's a bigger YouTuber, too??
(should we do it?)
( lets do it! )
Super cool. Super cool.
2016!
I don't think I- I was barely in this one. I was busy shooting uhhh... Scare PewDiePie.
I think I was going through my mental breakdown period.
Yeah it was YouTube- It was Scare PewDiePie season 2.
Yeahyeah- that was it.
And uh, I happened to be in their studio so they were like, "Dude we gotta have you in."
Really uh... really important role in that one. (sarcasm)
I always really enjoyed YouTube rewind. They do take a lot of time and I think you have to give up a day
and for someone that's on a daily YouTube grind that's a big deal. But it's worth it because it's such a cool production to be part of
even if it's just for 2 or 3 seconds. It became pretty clear to me at least that rewind isn't really
like, in 2012 when I first saw it I was like, "Okay this is something cool that all the creators are part of to celebrate YouTube."
But.. I mean, it's an advertisement. It's an advertisement for YouTube and that's fine.
I'm not saying that there's anything wrong with that but it's sorta like when you realize that, it doesn't really become the same thing
In my head at least, it used to be something that you wanted really to be acknowledged as a creator.
For 2017 YouTube Rewind...
I AM NOT IN IT.
Big surprise! I know!
It wasn't because I said no, it was because I wasn't asked.
Yeah.. no... it's- it's cool..
2017 has been quite the year.
It's sad in a way that I'm not part of it but like, I understand why.
Like I'm not salty at YouTube for not inviting me or something.
But at the end of the day I care more about YouTube. I care more about what's good for YouTube; what's good for the platform.
Than me being in it and I don't know... pissing people off? I don't know.
I haven't seen it yet but we'll watch it at the end of the video, I really want to react to it.
Some speculations; I wrote em down.
Lele Pons... There will be many Lele Pons!
we saw this from uh.. susan wojcicki's video.
we had a bunch of viners.
and that was like....
FAKKK!!!
probably some political uh.... statements
some the movement
probably
left!
Jake Paul
the Pauls, probably have a big part of it
I think
they had a, had a big influence on this year
so it makes sense
fidget spinners I have seen, because
they have teased it
hopefully some decent music this time around
probably, like
It's kinda a meme with the Rewind that you don't know who all the YouTubers are
because
but uh
I think that's a cool thing in a way, like
there's no way you know
what is it, like thousands of channels
have over a million subs, it's insane.
There's 2,000 channels, and this was in 2016
that have at least one million subscribers. Like, that's INSANE.
When they announced the Golden Plaque,
there was a dozen on it. There was a dozen of channels.
[YouTube Rewind music]
(not gonna lie, listening to this whilst subtitling the video makes me want to die)
Okay, they start off with the-
Latinoo?? Oh?
I don't- know, what is happening, it's too fast
I recognise Vanoss, obviously
and uh
Hola Soy German
oh my god, oh my god
What is hap-
fidget spinner!
Ah, that's dope.
I'm glad they got Kendrick, that's- that's really cool.
oke
Ayy, we got the meme in there, the-
great.
I feel like I'm reacting so badly to this,
there's not much to say really.
Uhmm..
oke
Faaaa... what? I don't
legit,
no offence, obviously,
they're in UK, right?
that looks like British churches to me,
maybe I'm wrong.
Who are they?
I didn't want to make this meme because it's so tired, but who-
this song will definitely cuck me over.
That's a cool SET.
Everybody, OF COURSE.
I'm glad they got Phil in there.
That's a bit weird- I don't think I've seen him in the others.
Yes.
YES.
UNITY!
H E  W I L L  N O T  D I V I D E  U S
I feel like I could've uh, I could've done that.
I definitely could've held someone's hand.
See, I could've been the middle part there, right?
Cmon, I ca-
[mating call]
You gotta admit,
I could've at least, maybe like
maybe I could've been like a subliminal message.
Uhhh, like a one frame sorta thing, like
uhhh, maybe joke about that
the whole uhhh Wall Street thing
maybe a little meme about it
That's the Kumbaya moment over with, that's nice
That's- that's also very cool.
There he is!
Of course.
I thought there'd be more of them, to be honest.
I thought they'd really focus on the Paulers.
Oh okay, there was more.
Oh yeah, because they had drama. Remember their drama?
Wow.
That's nice though.
I mean, it wouldn't be YouTube Rewind without acknowledging
the cancer.
Hey, it's Poppy.
Ah nice. I'm glad he's in it.
Not sure what they're going with here.
[laughs]
Ayy, we got Mark.
Man, I guess it's gotta be so hard to do this and fit all the people in,
right?
You got 2,000 channels.
2,000 with more than a million subs.
Planking, why?
Is it over?
Okay, it's over.
I think I hit all the predictions, didn't I?
I think, I think my favourite moments
was KSI.
Cos I thought he'd be hit by the train.
I'm joking. Ha ha ha ha.
Really, really enjoyed this bit.
This bit was really good.
This bit
10 out of 10.
Made me want to die.
I don't know why went with the greenscreen on this one, I just
had it down already as I couldn't be bothered to put it up
but uh
that's it.
Thank you for watching,
goodbye.
Squad fam out.